I worked on that idea of yours from a
song you want to hear it yeah you got
your lyrics Andy mm-hmm
[Music]
get in my car I'll drive you through the
canyon
breathe into panga for the day
[Music]
when we was the ocean and we can't go
further west we'll keep on driving any
way
go ahead
I'll take
you down
[Music]
and behind the dunes
I'll kiss your mouth
oh whiskey breath and then I'll leave
your heart
[Music]
maybe we could find a little city
forget the Stars
of Hollywood
a big old house
[Music]
I can introduce you to the angels of my
city but
[Music]
I'll drag you around
town by your ear
[Music]
still ringing from the rain
I'll buy your chips and tea
and beer and then I'll crush your heart
again
maybe we should meet in the middle
[Music]
and if we just gave us
maybe we could call it home
foreign